mike asks sims that means i'm asking you
fisher is the number one the first
number one overall pick in the draft to
catch a touchdown since who
wow okay hold on a second here hold on
let me just think because this is a
tricky one i don't think
this is not another offense alignment or
anything i feel like it's going to be
like a i'm going to say
i'm going to go like something crazy and
say peyton manning caught one on a
quarterback throwback
that's a good guess but you're wrong
okay it was keyshawn johnson the first
overall pick a year earlier wow peyton
manning a guy taking in the spot that
would have been peyton manning if if he
had come out a year early and the jets
had taken that's amazing i would think
that like some quarterback had caught
some sort of you know bull crap trick
play you know that's that really is
that he's the last number one pick to
catch a touchdown pass ex-teammate all
right johnson
let's get to it first for me and i'm not
i'm not letting this go i'm not letting
this go i i i've watched it over and
over again i don't accept mike
mccarthy's explanation tristan hill
for a goat go to the week for his
deliberate attempt to injure and
successful injury of chris carson the
seahawks running back there's no excuse
for it when you when you have both legs
i understand the the rolling technique
the seahawks teach that when you get the
guy on the ground your roll when you've
got him wrapped up when he's on the
ground and you've got one of his legs
and you violently do a barrel roll while
he's down and you know he's down that's
inexcusable that's intent to injure
mccarthy says there was no intent to
injure i say open your eyes and watch
the film there was intent to injure and
there should have been a suspension for
tristan hill so he gets the the first
pick without question for go to the week
yeah goodbye you he does he deserves it
that's uh it's bs it's a guy that's you
know i know had some immaturity problems
even coming out of college that's why he
kind of fell in the draft and that was
immature mean stupid whatever you want
to say has no place he knows exactly
every defender you can feel when the
guy's on the ground and you know when
he's on the ground and when you're
supposed to let go of a guy's leg and
not continue to barrel roll and hold on
to it and do it that way some bull crap
is what it is and i know mike mccarthy
is just trying to stick up for his
player but yeah i think deep down in his
heart he knows his bull crap too and
those to me like
i i this is like sometimes where i wish
the nfl would change the rule and be
like wait how many weeks is chris carson
out for the game oh he's out three weeks
well so is tristan hill then because
that was a cheap that was cheap shot he
shouldn't get to play as long as chris
carson's hurt hurt with that kind of
crap all right i'm gonna go to sunday
night football i'm gonna pick taysom
hill as my goat of the week you know not
not that he's we know he's talented and
a difference maker but
that game tor across midfield just had a
big fourth and one stop
it looks like everything is going in the
favor of the new orleans saints you know
the the the momentum had already swung
their way a little bit already where you
were going i don't know if the packers
can hang on and now they get the ball
back and you're going up well this is
trouble the saints are going to go down
and score he does that and it just
totally reversed things and the game was
never the same it was over after that
and the packers completely took back the
momentum and it was all because of that
one play game and the balance tasted
milk comes in unbelievable play by
zadaria smith but regardless it happened
and they lost uh in my opinion because
of that play
yeah i mean zerry smith made the play
but that doesn't mean you you fumble the
ball exactly hold on to the ball when
you see the guy coming right at you
secure the ball get tackled it was only
second down they would have had another
chance to get the first down i'm gonna
defend taysom hill though just a little
bit here yeah
if
it's hard you're not gonna if you're not
gonna use him yeah the way that you used
him last year the way you used him in
the playoff game don't use him at all on
offense or make him a pure decoy i mean
the problem is when you only get a
handful of chances per game
i i you're gonna be more stressed out
you're gonna be more freaked out you're
gonna be more determined to try to make
something happen because you're thinking
i should be getting 10 carries a game i
should be getting five catches a game i
should be throwing it seven times again
i think it's a good point and and when
you get that opportunity maybe you're
inclined to just kind of get a little
too
a little too overcome by the moment
trying to do everything trying to fill
up your stat sheet with that one
opportunity you get you know that that's
my defensive no i think you need to make
a decision you're right they need to use
him or not use him at all and let him be
the backup quarterback like every other
backup quarterback in the world i think
oh they're they're amazing points you're
right it's why i was reluctant to kind
of pick him a little bit i mean yeah he
fumbled the ball still but i mean you're
you're right i mean it's how do you it's
hard to get hey is it hard to write
articles on pft when you only get to do
one every now and then right you're
probably at your best when you're kind
of in a workflow and here i go and i'm
you know copy paste copy paste boom boom
boom here we go like it's hard to play
football and be that guy when i'm on the
bench oh i'm over here i'm doing this i
never really get the ball in my hand oh
now you want me to take over the game in
the most important situation okay also
to that too mike to what you're saying
is when green bay and you don't use him
consistently when he is there it's just
like bright lights bright lights he's
there they're not going to like use him
as a decoy here he hasn't touched the
ball in a quarter they're gonna give it
to him i think that's what caused the
fumble too i think sedarius smith was
like screw everything else taysom's
gonna take this and he went right at him
and i think taysom hill was a little
surprised by that which is what caused
him to fumble the ball
well and and i'm glad we i'm glad you
picked him i i had him on the list uh he
would have been my next pick but but uh
yeah yeah he deserves i understand
you're taking a length of it i love what
the saints do offensively and i've got
as much respect for sean payton as any
coach that's ever worked in the nfl but
pick a lane with taysom hill either use
him or put him on ice and make him your
backup quarterback all right next one
for me and there's several i can go with
i'm gonna go with dk metcalf for for
letting up at the goal line uh it would
have been six touchdown passes for
russell wilson i mean
everything has to play out from that
point forward but but still you don't
let up he learned a valuable lesson uh
we think dk metcalf's one of the best
receivers in the nfl if not the very
best we got to hold him to a high
standard so he deserves this recognition
for letting up at the goal line and
losing the ball out of the end zone and
then the stupidest rule in football
kicks in and gives dallas possession at
the 20. no great rule i did i great pick
by you at dk matt gaff he they lost the
ball in dallas territory and went into
no man's land it's dallas ball that's
their territory he lost it in north
korea kim jong-un and the cowboys got
the ball now okay that's the way that
goes you good all right you don't lose
the ball in north korea it's not yours
anymore once you do that
all right all right go ahead
um
i don't even this this one's so big i
don't even know where to start but i
mean goats in a bad way i'm picking the
falcons offense uh matt ryan calvin
ridley the offensive line they all
deserve it they all deserve for the crap
they've done for two weeks in a row not
being able to put a football game away
not showing any toughness to be able to
run the ball in a moment to chew up the
clock to help your team out all that
money on that offense nobody can get a
freaking first down 90 zillion dollars
well that's what happens when you build
a team that's all about four players oh
i mean julio jones is not playing now
the offense becomes about two players
and it's just not that good it's not the
roster's not that good the offense isn't
special it's not a special scheme it's
just guys that are kind of talented that
can you know make it look good on a
weekly basis but as you can see they
they wilt away against good teams always
eventually and it just matt ryan the
offense the approach the toughness of
the falcons on offense the gm everybody
they all deserve it can't they they
don't just uh you can't escape the blame
on that one
all right since you picked like all
those different people i'm gonna do a
combo for my last one i'm gonna go lamar
jackson and greg roman because i think
it's a shared responsibility between
offensive coordinator and quarterback to
come up with a plan and implement a plan
that is going to work you know the
stakes you know the size of the stage
this game has been circled since the day
that they announced the schedule you got
to come up with something better than 97
passing yards against the defending
champions if you want to be the next
champions if they are your kryptonite
and look lamar jackson says it publicly
last night within the building they they
know the vibe they know how important
this game is they know what the stakes
are and and for the the game plan and
the execution of the game plan to be
that poor offensively yeah both guys
deserve the blame and both guys had
better do a better job if they cross
paths with the chiefs again chris yeah i
agree there's going to have to be a
different approach by that whole
football team but yes certainly them
whether that's come out and be throw
first or more creative run game design
whatever it is but that approach is not
working against that football team and
as we know football's about matchups you
can match up good with one team one week
and then the next team you go yeah we're
better our record's better but man
they're a tough matchup for us and
kansas city has proven to be that way
for the ravens all right i think i got
to go dwayne haskins with this last one
i mean dwayne haskins i think job is you
know teetering as far as a stark
starting quarterback with the washington
football team and again some of those
mistakes
the way he played i mean that defense
kept them in the game
you know even special teams there's a
good punt in return they throw a guy
screen short pass over there they get
down they score at 17 13. they're
hanging around in this football game and
he continued to make mistakes that
really gave them no chance to win it so
dwayne haskins is a guy i look at he's
got to clean up his act a little better
he's going to be on the bench here soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports